[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen am
weltfrauentag wir bringen sie in den
nächsten 20 minuten auf den neuesten
nachrichten stand die vom sport hat aber
kämen mit weiteren deutschen medaille
bei den paralympics genannt in der
ukraine gab es heute zumindest für
einige menschen einen lichtblick
erste flucht korridore wurden geöffnet
hunderte zivilisten konnten während
einer feuerpause aus der umkämpften
stadt sony gerettet werden
aber die russischen angriffe gehen
weiter und die usa verschärfen ihre
sanktionen gegen moskau mit einem
importstopp für russisches öl
inzwischen sind laut uno mehr als zwei
millionen menschen aus der ukraine
geflohen
die hilferufe werden immer lauter in
mario pohl sei die lage apokalyptisch
berichtet das internationale rote kreuz
der bürgermeister von haag wirft den
russischen truppen vor gezielt
kindergärten schulen und kliniken
beschossen zu haben beide seiten geben
sich gegenseitig die schuld dass kaum
ein flucht korridor funktioniert aber
immerhin erstmals konnten einige hundert
menschen evakuiert werden thomas garcia
und julia schröter
der bus mit dem roten kreuz bedeutet
hoffnung raus endlich raus aus sumy nach
tagen der kämpfe und der angst kurz
schweigen die waffen einen flucht
korridor wie es technisch heißt nutzt
die fahrzeugkolonne für die menschen ist
es eine chance zu überleben und das
hinter sich zu lassen noch in der nacht
hatte es luftangriffe gegeben nach
ukrainischen angaben auch auf wohnhäuser
mindestens 21 menschen sollen ums leben
gekommen sein am morgen liegen teile der
270.000 einwohner stadt unter schnee und
asche die evakuierungsaktion führt 170
kilometer weiter nach poltawa
die stadt blieb bisher von direkten
kämpfen verschont auch aus dem raum kiew
luftkorridor geplant ihn am rand der
hauptstadt
viele verkehrswege hier sind zerstört
flucht zu fuß es sind hunderte
sie kann kaum gehen aber wir versuchen
es wenigstens
japan ist komplett zerstört
wir müssen fliehen in unserer wohnung
hatten wir temperaturen von zehn grad
und es wurde noch kälter
kiew der präsident zeigt sich
demonstrativ will mut machen
ebenso die nationalhymne aus
lautsprechern
doch die bewohner haben angst langsam
auf den eco ist in der hauptstadt
geblieben mit ihrem mann und ihrer
mutter das video gespräch muss sie
unterbrechen ein alarmsignal warnt vor
einem angriff
trotz der gefahr zögert sie zu fliehen
die korridore sind eine farce sie
existieren eigentlich nicht das hat sich
in ihr team gezeigt auch gestern gab es
dort einen korridor die zivilisten
wurden beschossen dabei sind habe ich
gehört sieben menschen gestorben
auch kinder
angriffe auf geplante fluchtrouten die
heißt es gebe es auch anderswo nahm
mario pohl etwa erstmals seit tagen gibt
es einblicke bilder gestern gedreht die
stadt umlagert häuser die infrastruktur
zerstört und die verzweiflung groß
wir haben keinen strom wir haben nichts
zu essen keine medizin wir haben nichts
[Musik]
weil in den supermärkten nichts mehr zu
finden ist weil chaos herrscht werden
menschen in mariupol
plünderern diese floh vertreibt einen
dieb verteidigt ihren laden
alle versuchen zu überleben irgendwie im
wahnsinn dieses krieges
katrin eigendorf ist weiterhin für uns
in der ukraine in der mitte des landes
katrin zum ersten mal hat heute
zumindest ein flucht korridor
funktioniert wie wird das bei ihnen vor
ort bewertet
ja das ist ein ganz ganz winziger
hoffnungsschimmer aber wir sind ja
selber auch in einer stadt in der sehr
sehr viele flüchtlinge ankommen
die im prinzip sich auf den weg richtung
lief also in die west ukraine machen die
auch aus dem osten kommen aber auch aus
kiew und alles was die uns berichten ist
dass die lage katastrophal ist dass
flüchtlinge die städte verlassen bewusst
von russischen truppen beschossen werden
dass die humanitäre lage in städten wie
hp aber auch mario pohl sich immer
weiter zuspitzt dass man wirklich darauf
hinausläuft dass die leute dort nichts
mehr zu essen haben dass es an wasser
fehlt an lebensmitteln und auch
medikamenten also die menschen schildern
uns hier übereinstimmend wirklich
katastrophale zustände wir waren hier
heute auch am bahnhof da kam ein zug
durch der hat kurz gehalten der fuhr
richtung lief kam aus kiew der war so
vollgestopft dass die leute fast aus dem
zug rausgefallen sind die saßen in den
gängen und dann kamen helfer an und
haben wasserflaschen reingeschmissen
babynahrung also das sind wirklich
erschütternde bilder das ist eine
humanitäre katastrophe das wird ja auch
von internationalen hilfsorganisationen
bestätigt und ich sehe da in der
gesamtlage nicht unbedingt eine große
veränderung sondern eher eine zuspitzung
der lage russland greift weiter brutal
zivilisten an und wirklich effektive
fluchtwege gibt es hier nicht vielen
dank für diese eindrücke katrin
eigendorf aus filmen ski
seit tagen wird diskutiert russland
wirtschaftlich noch stärker unter druck
zu setzen mit einem boykott von große öl
oder gas das würde allerdings die
energiepreise noch weiter nach oben
treiben trotzdem geht die us regierung
jetzt diesen schritt vor zwei stunden
kündigte präsident biden an den import
von öl aus russland zu verbieten aus
washington claudia bates
präsident biden stand innenpolitisch
unter druck von allen seiten die
ölimporte aus russland zu stoppen auch
ohne die europäischen verbündeten
und die amerikaner unterstützen
geschlossen das ukrainische volk wir
werden putins krieg nicht mitfinanzieren
tour
die usa sind selbst der weltweit grösste
ölproduzent nur knapp acht prozent rohöl
und ölprodukte werden aus russland
importiert der ölpreis auf einem 13
jahreshoch macht die förderung auch
fracking umso rentabler die usa also
deutlich weniger abhängig von russischem
öl als europa
meine der eine reaktion auf putins
aggression ist mein hauptaugenmerk dass
die nato die eu und allen verbündeten
vollkommen geschlossen handeln wir
verhängen dieses verbot im verständnis
dass viele unserer europäischen partner
vielleicht nicht mitziehen können für
sich
doch die benzinpreise steigen rasant
liegen zurzeit bei etwa einem dollar pro
liter für die usa fast rekordhöhe so gab
der präsident ölreserven frei um die
preise kurzfristig abzufedern und die us
regierung verhandelt sogar mit venezuela
den putin verbündeten maduro erkennt sie
als präsidentin nicht an ist aber
interessiert an seinem öl
venezuela wird immer jeden vorstoß
anführen in ölmarkt den gasmarkt den
energiemarkt zu stabilisieren wir sind
bereit
ungewöhnliche allianzen doch beiden ist
entschlossen nun den energiesektor zu
treffen die hauptschlagader der
russischen wirtschaft
wollen wir unsere korrespondenten in
washington und brüssel dazu zuerst zu
elmar theveßen die wirkung von
sanktionen ist umstritten immer was
erhofft sich der präsident von diesem
importverbot
das weiße haus will zeigen dass man den
druck auf russland weiter verstärken
will und auch kann amerika verzichtet
auf milliardeneinnahmen durch diesen
stopp eben der importe aus russland
und auch wenn nicht alle verbündete im
gleichen ausmaß mitmachen soll es eben
auch das signal senden an russland dass
die energiewirtschaft dort mittelfristig
keine zukunft hat wenn wladimir putin
nicht deeskaliert in dieser krise denn
die anderen verbündeten denken ja auch
langfristig über veränderungen nach und
das ist das wichtigste dritte was den
präsidenten am herzen liegt man will
gemeinsam und einig mit allen
verbündeten raus aus der abhängigkeit
von öl weltweit langfristig gesehen
damit so heißt es hier kein land der
erde in der lage ist öl noch als waffe
in der zukunft zu benutzen das
ausgerechnet vom größten ölproduzenten
wie realistisch das ist das werden wir
sehen aber zunächst mal muss man das
russische öl ja ersetzen eben aus öl
lieferungen von venezuela saudi arabien
und dem iran möglicherweise
gehen wir weiter nach brüssel der us
präsident sagte er habe sich mit den
europäern abgesprochen florian neumann
wird die eu nachziehen
in der öffentlichen debatte wird der
druck natürlich steigen auf europa dass
man nach zieht aber wieder mal ist der
eindruck dass europa hat während die usa
eben vorpreschen aber dieser eindruck
ist meines erachtens nicht ganz gerecht
denn anders als die usa ist europa eben
immer noch in hohem maße abhängig von
russischen energieimporten da zeigen
sich die versäumnisse der vergangenheit
insofern die eu kommission hat heute
erstmal einen plan vorgestellt wie man
die eu die gasimporte aus russland
reduziert um zwei drittel innerhalb
eines jahres schon das ist ehrgeizig man
setzt auf andere energielieferanten man
setzt auf erneuerbare energien
und man will die gasspeicher bis zum
herbst wieder massiv füllen aber stand
jetzt wird man keinen kompletten energie
stopp energie importstopp aus russland
verhängen man wird erst mal abwarten
hinter behalten noch und wenn wir alles
in dieser krise aber gelernt haben ist
ja auch das was heute noch als
unverrückbar gilt das kann sich morgen
schon wieder ändern sofern die nächsten
tage da könnte es noch etwas bewegung in
der debatte geben dankeschön für diese
informationen live aus washington und
brüssel
und deutschland wie sicher ist unsere
energieversorgung darüber beriet
wirtschaftsminister habe heute mit den
kollegen aus den ländern gestern hatte
die russische regierung erstmals damit
gedroht gaslieferungen nach deutschland
zu stoppen das würde vor allem zwei
gruppen hart treffen die industrie sie
ist für etwa ein drittel des deutschen
gasverbrauchs verantwortlich die
privathaushalte liegen nur knapp
dahinter aber zum beispiel auch für die
stromerzeugung und andere bereiche
spielt das eine rolle peter theißen über
teure energie gas und öl
fazli collmex verkauft so viel heizöl
wie nie zu dieser jahreszeit und das
obwohl es so teuer ist wie nie zuvor die
kundschaft haben angst oder die wir
fischen dass die preise noch extreme
nach oben geht um wohl ist momentan
wirklich das doppel weiß was vor 14 tage
die schlechte nachricht durch den krieg
in der ukraine könnten die preise für öl
und benzin noch weiter steigen deshalb
heute krisensitzung der deutschen
energieminister robert habeck fordert
internationale solidarität die spannende
frage wird sein ob der weltmarkt mal
nachzieht und beispielsweise die opec
ihre fördermenge erhöht dass wir jetzt
tatsächlich einen beitrag zur entlastung
also insofern der dringende appell wenn
die dann auf mich hören die fördermenge
hochzusetzen einigkeit bei der video
konferenz darüber dass der ausbau der
erneuerbaren jetzt beschleunigt werden
muss die erneuerbaren energien bedeuten
auf freiheit das muss man immer wieder
dazu sagen und die windenergieanlage
horizont bekommt damit vielleicht ein
anderes bild und eine andere wahrnehmung
doch erst einmal kommen auch auf die
industrie riesige herausforderungen zu
vor allem auf die energieintensiven
branchen wie die zement- oder
chemieindustrie
deren produktionskosten werden teurer
und natürlich beeinträchtigt das die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit
auch wenn er gerade sehr viel teures
heizöl verkauft fast ecall mitchell
hofft dass der krieg bald vorbei ist und
dass er die preise für seine kunden
wieder senken kann
nur mit dem nötigsten bepackt fliegen
die menschen vor dem krieg aus der
ukraine
mittlerweile sind es mehr als zwei
millionen mehr als die hälfte von ihnen
hat polen aufgenommen unter den vielen
freiwilligen die sie empfangen sind
jetzt auch französische feuerwehrleute
in deutschland sind mindestens
60.000 geflüchtete angekommen auch hier
werden die schlangen vor den
erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen immer länger
einige länder haben für die verteilung
bereits hilfe vom bund angefordert
und wenn sie den geflüchteten und den
menschen in der ukraine helfen und
geldspenden wollen dann können sie das
tun zum beispiel beim aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe
bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine alle
infos auch unter spenden zdf.de oder im
zdf text auf seite 8 190 der krieg die
vielen flüchtlinge auch heute
informieren wir sie in einem zdf spezial
gleich nach dieser sendung auch in
unsere zdf heute app gibt es jederzeit
aktuelle informationen zum krieg
jetzt zur afd ist die partei eine gefahr
für die demokratie
im kern ist es diese frage mit der sich
das verwaltungsgericht in köln
beschäftigt konkret geht es um vier
klagen der afg gegen das bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz die wohl wichtigste
betrifft die frage ob der
verfassungsschutz die gesamte partei als
verdachtsfall einstufen und beobachten
darf christian dieker
afg politikerinnen und politiker fallen
immer wieder mit umstrittenen äußerungen
auf
daraus wiederum wegen derartige
äußerungen will der verfassungsschutz
die gesamte afd beobachten dagegen wehrt
sich die partei und hat geklagt
insgesamt muss ja auch geklärt werden
was darf eigentlich in diesem land noch
eine opposition was darf eine opposition
eigentlich in diesem land noch sagen was
ist sagt wie weit ist die
meinungsfreiheit mittlerweile schon vom
grundgesetz entfernt der
verfassungsschutz will die afg vom
bloßen prüfen zum verdachtsfall
hochstufen der unterschied als prüfwerte
der verfassungsschutz nur frei
zugängliche quellen aus als
verdachtsfall kann er auch
nachrichtendienstliche maßnahmen
einsetzen zum beispiel
telefonüberwachung oder v leute für die
afg hätte dies massive folgen
parteifunktionäre wurden abgehört ihre e
mails mitgelesen beamte unter den
mitgliedern müssten mit prüfverfahren
rechnen als beleg hat der
verfassungsschutz viele afd beiträge
gesammelt zum beispiel dieses zitat aus
einer jet gruppe ohne umsturz und
revolution erreichen wir hier keinen
kurswechsel mehr die zentrale frage im
prozess ist ist das was der
verfassungsschutz über monate und jahre
zur afg gesammelt hat geht das über
bloße meinungsäußerung harsche kritik am
politischen gegner hinaus denn das
wirklich extremistische äußerungen die
sich auch die partei als gesamtheit
zuordnen lassen diese fragen muss das
gericht klären noch heute abend könnte
ein urteil fallen
bei der aktuellen lage gerät die korona
pandemie fast etwas aus dem fokus dabei
steigen die zahlen weiter das robert
koch institut meldet
156 1799 neuinfektionen binnen 24
stunden über 34.000 mehr als vor einer
woche
324 todesfälle kamen innerhalb eines
tages dazu die sieben tage incidents
liegt aktuell bei über
1.200 93
heute ist weltfrauentag er macht darauf
aufmerksam wie häufig frauen immer noch
benachteiligt sind oder gar um leib und
leben fürchten müssen so gingen in paris
tausende menschen auf die straße um
unter anderem gegen sexualisierte gewalt
zu demonstrieren
in der philippinischen hauptstadt manila
forderten frauen essen arbeit und
sozialleistungen und in berlin wo diese
achte märz seit 2009 10 feiertag ist
riefen die demonstrantinnen auch zum
stopp des krieges in der ukraine auf
den weltfrauentag hat die gewerkschaft
verdi zum anlass genommen kita
beschäftigte bundesweit zu warnstreiks
aufzurufen
viele einrichtungen blieben deswegen
heute geschlossen verdi will so den
druck in den laufenden
tarifverhandlungen erhöhen um die
arbeitsbedingungen für die erzieherinnen
und erzieher zu verbessern zum beispiel
durch mehr geld und maßnahmen gegen den
fachkräftemangel
und jetzt sind wir bei den paralympics
norbert wieder ein erfolgreicher tor
fürs deutsche team einmal den kompletten
medaillensatz im biathlon in der
sitzenden klasse holten martin fleig
silber und anja wicker bronze und für
eine echte sensation sorgte die 18
jährige leonie walter gold bei den see
beeinträchtigten frauen der große moment
der es sehbehinderten leonie walter und
ihres kevin strecker die 18-jährige
legte die grundlage zu gold mit 20
fehlerfreien schüssen die dank
akustischer signale möglich sind nach
zielankunft nochmal großes bangen die
ukrainerin chico war mit starken
schlussspurt aber letztlich blieben
walter 3,7 sekunden vorsprung
ich habe gewartet bis die wirklich hat
es gereicht hat es dich gereicht dann
kommt die zeit dann kam die zeit und
irgendwann sind alle aufgesprungen gerne
rad ist klar okay ich habe
martin fleig erkämpfte in der sitzenden
klasse silber besser als er war über die
zehn kilometer distanz nur der chinesin
in der gleichen stadt klasse gewarnt die
stuttgarterin anja bäcker dann
großartiger laufleistung bronze
schläger zertrümmert schiedsrichter
beschimpft alexanders wehres ausraster
beim turnier in acapulco hat folgen
25.000 dollar geldstrafe und acht wochen
sperre auf bewährung entschied die
herren tennis organisation atp heute
abend das achtelfinal-rückspiel in der
fußball-champions-league münchen gegen
salzburg das hinspiel in österreich
endete 1 1 für die bayern ist ein sieg
und damit der einzug ins viertelfinale
pflicht wieder mit nationaltorhüter
manuel neuer geht das team von trainer
nagelsmann in das bisher wichtigste
match dieser spielzeit natürlich ist ein
bedeutendes spiel wenn es nicht positiv
ausgeht dann ist jetzt keine besondere
saison nach dem 1 zu einzelnen
salzburger hinspiel vor drei wochen muss
für beide mannschaften um weiterzukommen
heute ein sieg her am wochenende beim 1
1 gegen leverkusen schoss thomas müller
das erste eigentor in seiner langen
karriere umso mehr wird er darauf achten
den ball heute abend wieder in des
gegners tor unterzubringen
das wassersport dankeschön das wetter
bietet weiter balsam für die seele mit
viel sonne aber frostigen nächten die
details hat gleich katja horneffer
danach folgt das zdf spezial und um kurz
vor 10 begrüßt sie christian sievers im
heute journal
alles gute ihnen danke für ihr interesse
und bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend auch heute strahlte die
sonne von dänemark bis zu den alpen und
nur hier über den bodensee gab es mal so
ein paar schleierwolken
so ist es auch heute nacht klar und
höchstens hier in mecklenburg vorpommern
bildet sich mal etwas nebel die
temperaturen sinken an den küsten von
nord- und ostsee und auch am niederrhein
auf 1 grad sonst geht's auf minus zwei
bis minus zehn grad runter und morgen
liegen die höchsttemperaturen an der
ostseeküste bei 7 grad in den
mittelgebirgen werden es neun grad
häufig aber sind es zweistellige werte
und am niederrhein wird es mit 15 grad
am mildesten dazu strahlt auch morgen
wieder häufig die sonne es gibt nur
wenige harmlose wolken und der wind
kommt aus östlichen bis südöstlichen
richtungen an diesem wetter ändert sich
auch am donnerstag und am freitag wenig
am niederrhein wird sogar noch mal ein
bisschen bildet bis zu 17 grad am
samstag werden dann die wolken von
westen etwas dichter und jetzt schauen
wir noch mal ganz woanders sind nämlich
nach australien vielleicht haben sie die
bilder gesehen es gab ja noch einmal
kräftige regenfälle rund um sydney
menschen mussten in sicherheit gebracht
werden und die gute nachricht für sydney
ist dass dieses tief morgen dann sich
richtung süden verabschiedet guten abend